[Music]
Kitt's I changed my mind I'm staying as
CEO head of the firm you [ __ ] me three
years ago you were still in the nuthouse
dad it's called rehab and I'm in
recovery
dad wild out is L the family proposes
that Kendall run the company with Romina
Co oh yes I'm not saying I would make a
better CEO that's unsaid it's not unsaid
when you say do you know that he gave me
a job why would I cuz I thought
everybody's might be talking about me
yeah no everyone was only talking about
you cousin Greg come in and see me and
I'll look after you he stays here he
gets better here well we can discuss no
no discussion
I am his next of kin I am his proxy I am
in charge thank you
this is really happening you're getting
married and that is a very romantic way
of looking at prenup
that's the death pit right I feel like I
might not like it in the death pit all
you have to do is go to the office do a
little bit of shredding took a job
shooting bolts into cows heads is a job
but somehow I want to spend my
Thanksgiving does not well he's not
careful he's gonna destroy the company
the only way he'll respect you is if he
tried to destroy him I love my father
but he is currently unfit to run this
company and I'm calling for a vote of no
confidence in him as CEO and chairman
[ __ ] No
all in favor you better be smelling your
[ __ ] armpit Romulus against this
family's broken and that has
consequences
but dad's gonna try and win at therapy
money hasn't done therapy with me is
what it looks like when you resolve all
your issues
I want to talk about you properly come
in I've always thought you were the
smartest that's why you tried Kendall
and Roman first why are you so jumpy
about this Ken why am i jumpy about
taking the company out of family control
forever this is a [ __ ] bear hug [ __ ]
off to fundamentally alter the nature of
the family on my wedding day any
conception how goddamn selfish you are
have you had your entire life that I
didn't give you I spoiled you know
you're [ __ ] this could be the defining
moment of your life
[Music]
you
[Music]
you